an Uber Eats driver was dismembered
in Florida and Florida is it's being
sold to everybody as the state and I
love parts of Florida there's parts of
Florida that I love Palm Beach
now but the red there is a rest of it
now obviously that Miami is great and
I'm kidding the West Coast Tampa and
Saint Pete oh that's great but you do
have to remember that 90 of Florida
geographically is an unlivable hell
where things go on
and it's not it's not a political
statement I'm not like and that's Rhonda
Santa says fault no it's just this is a
place where people eat each other
this is a place where there is you know
behavior that is biblical biblical
Behavior where you look at it and you go
this is something I don't even
understand I don't even understand this
Chicago we get it the shootings you're
on my block I'm on your block boom boom
you know there's maybe a little more but
not that much Florida's like I'm gonna
dismember someone I'm gonna dissolve
them in a bathtub uh I'm gonna choke a
pit bull things you don't think about
you know you don't think about someone
choking a pit bull but people do and
they do it in Florida a demonic MS-13
gang member by the way I'm not saying
that the New York Post is so I have no
issue with the salvadorians uh demonic
MS-13 gang member robbed and dismembered
an Uber each driver in Florida for no
apparent reason last week Oscar Solas 30
who moved to the Sunshine State
in January after being sprung on parole
from Indiana allegedly yanked Randall
crook
60 and was home on April 19th and
butchered him
God cook was making his final delivery
of the night
and that should be the Eli Roth movie at
the next one I do called the final
delivery
Eli Roth will call me he'll be like so
there's a movie called final it's called
final delivery and it's based on the
MS-13 driver who's uh dismembered in his
home
um so he's just a guy trying to make a
living for his family that's what
they're all saying
and
he brings him in the house and then he
chops them up what would what would
motivate
someone to do that
how late
was this guy can we look at that is
there is there because I've gotten
delivery I ordered delivery once from a
Mexican restaurant and it was so it had
moved around so much in the car when you
opened it up the guacamole was all on
the top like the roof of the styrofoam
and there was just like one Taquito see
I didn't even know where the rest of
them were there are
there are like mitigating factors I
think to this where it's like and by the
way what was the order can we do we know
the or can we find out the order
the final delivery but this is what I
mean you know months ago I talked about
the gig economy being a horror movie
what the gig economy is is you're just
out there hoping someone doesn't kill
you that's really what it is you're
hoping to God the person who gets into
your Uber or walks into Walmart doesn't
shoot you eat you maim you because as
the drugs get more potent and as the
people that are doing these things are
just out in the open and they deal
directly with you you're they're at your
doorstep they're handing you food you're
sitting in the back of a car and you
know they're sitting in the back of your
car and you're driving them to their who
knows they're you know so at the end of
the day it's like the gig economy which
is you know the the delivery and the
Uber and things like that let alone the
uh department stores where you're a
Sitting Duck you're literally sitting
here these things have just this
increased likelihood now that one of
them is going to end incredibly bad
incredibly bad you read about them all
the time you read about these all the
time where you're driving an Uber and
then somebody gets in
and you wonder if someone knows like do
you know you wonder if somebody knows
because people say they get premonitions
before they die this is what people say
does someone know when they accept this
delivery and they go to I'm going to say
El Pollo Loco because I missed our team
but I don't know it might have been
Italian I don't know do they know when
they pick up that food and when they're
driving to this guy's house do they feel
a little bit in the pit of their stomach
like this could be maybe this is it
maybe this is the last Taquito I drop
off this might be the last burrito I
hand a guy what a horrible way to die
you just hand them food and then he
Yanks you the way the article was
written he Yanks you in and now you're
in his lair you're in the dungeon now
that's how you get kids to pay attention
in school go sure you could do Uber Eats
but I'll tell you you might get yanked
into the lair of an MS-13 guy who eats
you
so do you want to do your homework or
not
what are they saying here so they've
asked the wife but she didn't share the
details of it well why
seems pretty personal yeah
so he was dismembered
and the guy's been charged with felony
murder
um
of course but this is what they're
saying you're saying he wasn't in his
right mind he was probably on drugs this
is what they are saying I mean these
people look
you know like good people here this is
bring that get that up there that's
really really sad this is crazy what are
you doing Uber Eats for in Florida I
know people have to and that's the
comments I'm gonna go oh you're out of
touch
you got the Fourteen thousand dollar
sunglasses you're out of touch you don't
understand it people have to do a breeds
I know but
do ya is there nothing else to do look
at that that's who you're delivering
food to bring that up
that's who you're there should be a
photo of him
on the delivery where you go no I'm not
bringing a burrito to him he's gotta get
it if you do that to your face you have
to go out and get your food if you do
that you shouldn't you are not getting
home delivery
I'm not bringing you an eggs benedict at
9am you have to go out and get your food
through a drive-through I mean that's
nuts